Cuando D comenzó la escuela aquí tenía seis años:
tierno como un botón,
Con una sonrisa que iluminó toda la habitación.
Pero después de unos meses en la escuela,
D se enojó,
y esa sonrisa se desvaneció.
D comenzó a hacer cosas como voltear mesas,
tirar escritorios y sillas,
gritar a los maestros,
en los alféizares de las ventanas,
entrar y salir del aula
e incluso salir corriendo de la escuela.
A veces, estos ataques de ira podían bloquear a toda la escuela
hasta que D lograba recuperarse,
lo que a veces podía llevar más de una hora.
Nadie en la escuela sabía cómo ayudar a D.
Lo sé porque yo era la directora de esta escuela.
Y lo que aprendí rápida y colectivamente con mi personal
fue que esta situación era más extrema.
que cualquier otra cosa para la que hubiéramos sido entrenados.
Cada vez que D atacaba,
seguía pensando para mí misma:
¿qué me perdí durante mi curso de preparación como directora?
¿Qué se supone que debo hacer con un niño como D?
¿Y cómo voy a evitar que bloquee el aprendizaje
de todos los demás estudiantes?
Y, sin embargo, después hacer todo lo que creíamos saber,
como hablar con D
y quitarle privilegios
y llamar a los padres a casa,
la única opción real que nos quedaba por hacer era echarlo,
Y sabía que eso no le ayudaría.
Este escenario no es exclusivo de D.
Los estudiantes de todo el mundo están luchando con su educación.
Y aunque no se nos ocurrió una solución a prueba de fallos,
se nos ocurrió una idea simple:
que para que niños como D no solo sobrevivan en la escuela
sino que prosperen
de alguna manera teníamos que encontrar una manera
no solo para enseñarles a leer y escribir,
sino también cómo ayudarles a lidiar y manejar sus propias emociones.
Y al hacer eso, pudimos mover nuestra escuela.
de una de las escuelas de menor rendimiento en el estado de Ohio,
con una calificación de F,
todo el camino hasta una C en unos pocos años.
Así que puede sonar obvio, ¿verdad?
Por supuesto, los maestros deben centrarse en el bienestar emocional de sus niños.
Pero en la realidad,
cuando estás en un aula llena de 30 estudiantes
y uno de ellos te está tirando mesas,
es mucho más fácil excluir a ese niño
que averiguar qué está pasando dentro de su cabeza.
Pero lo que aprendimos sobre D,
y para niños como D,
fue que los pequeños cambios pueden hacer grandes diferencias,
y es posible empezar ahora mismo.
No necesitas grandes presupuestos ni grandes planes estratégicos,
simplemente se necesita formas más inteligentes de pensar en lo que se tiene
y donde lo tienes.
En educación, siempre buscamos respuestas fuera de lo estándar,
y rara vez gastamos suficiente tiempo, dinero y esfuerzo
desarrollando lo que ya tenemos dentro del estándar.
Y así es cómo el cambio significativo puede suceder rápidamente.
Así que aquí está lo que aprendí acerca de D.
Quería profundizar un poco más para descubrir cómo se enfadaba tanto.
Y lo que supe fue que su padre había abandonado el hogar.
y su madre trabajaba largos turnos para mantener a la familia,
lo que dejó a D sin ningún adulto con el que conectar
y se le encargó cuidar a su hermano menor
cuando llegaba a casa de la escuela.
Les recuerdo que D tenía seis años.
¿Puedo entonces decir que lo culpo por tener problemas
de transición al entorno escolar.
Sin embargo, teníamos que encontrar formas de ayudarlo con esas grandes emociones
todo mientras le enseñábamos habilidades básicas de lectura y matemáticas.
Y tres cosas nos ayudaron más.
Primero, tuvimos que averiguar dónde luchaba más.
Como la mayoría de los pequeños,
llegar a la escuela puede ser un tiempo de transición difícil
al cambiar de un entorno doméstico menos estructurado
a un entorno escolar más estructurado.
Y lo que hicimos para D fue crear un área de calma para él
en nuestra sala de descanso,
que habíamos equipado con mecedoras y suaves cojines y libros,
y permitimos que D fuera a este lugar por la mañana,
lejos de los otros niños,
dándole tiempo para volver al ambiente escolar
en sus propios términos.
Y a medida que comenzamos a aprender más sobre D,
aprendimos otras estrategias que lo ayudaron a calmarse.
Por ejemplo, a D le encantaba ayudar a los estudiantes más jóvenes,
así que le hicimos un ayudante de jardín de infancia,
y se iba al aula infantil
y enseñaba a los alumnos cómo escribir sus cartas.
Y fue tan exitoso con algunos de ellos
que el profesor no lo pudo alcanzar.
Y lo crean o no,
D en realidad ayudó a calmar a algunos de esos estudiantes de kindergarten,
mostrándonos que la influencia de los compañeros en el comportamiento
era mucho mayor que cualquier cosa que los adultos pudiéramos hacer.
Usamos el humor y las canciones con él.
Sí, ya sé que suena muy tonto
que el director y los maestros realmente se reían con los niños,
pero ¿pueden imaginarse el impacto en la cara de D
cuando la directora bromea o canta una canción de la radio,
lo que casi siempre terminaba en una risa,
acortando así el tiempo de su arrebato
y ayudándonos a conectar con él en su mundo?
Así que sé que algunos piensan:
"Realmente no es práctico aplicar este tipo de tratamiento especial
para cada estudiante",
pero de verdad lo hicimos realidad.
Porque al descubrir las herramientas y tácticas que sirvieron con D,
nuestros maestros pudieron extender eso y usarlo con otros estudiantes.
Comenzamos a abordar proactivamente el comportamiento de los estudiantes.
en lugar de simplemente reaccionar a él.
Nuestros maestros tomaron tiempo durante el plan de clase
para enseñar a los niños a identificar sus sentimientos
y afrontarlos con estrategias saludables y apropiadas,
tales como contar hasta 10,
usar un juguete girador
o dar un paseo rápido.
Incorporamos descansos mentales a lo largo del día,
permitiendo a los niños cantar,
hacer posturas de yoga
y participar en actividades físicas estructuradas.
Y para aquellos niños que luchan con sentarse por largos períodos de tiempo,
invertimos en asientos flexibles,
mecedoras y bicicletas estáticas,
e incluso máquinas elípticas de suelo,
permitiendo a los niños pedalear debajo de sus escritorios.
Estos cambios animaron a los niños a permanecer en el aula,
ayudándoles a concentrarse y aprender.
Y cuando menos niños están perturbando,
a todos los niños les va mejor.
Y aquí está la cosa mágica:
no nos costó mucho dinero extra.
Simplemente pensamos diferente acerca de lo que teníamos.
Por ejemplo, cada escuela pública tiene una línea de equipos de instrucción.
Un equipo de instrucción podría ser un libro,
podría ser una pizarra,
podría ser asiento flexible,
podría ser un juguete girador,
Incluso podría pintar las paredes de una escuela de un color más calmado,
permitiendo a los estudiantes prosperar.
No es que no hayamos invertido en las herramientas académicas...
obviamente...
pero también tomamos en serio las herramientas sociales.
Y los resultados hablan por sí mismos.
Tomando en serio el desarrollo emocional de nuestros niños.
y ayudándoles a manejar sus emociones,
vimos un gran crecimiento en nuestros resultados de lectura y matemáticas,
superando con creces el año de crecimiento esperado
y superando a muchas escuelas con nuestra misma demografía.
Lo segundo para ayudar a nuestros niños a manejar sus emociones.
fue que utilizar apalancamiento.
Como una escuela pública no tan financiada,
no teníamos el personal de apoyo
para enfrentar el caos que nuestros niños podrían estar enfrentando en casa,
y ciertamente no estábamos entrenados o financiados para abordarlo directamente.
Así que empezamos a llegar a los grupos locales,
agencias comunitarias,
e incluso la Universidad Estatal de Ohio.
Nuestra asociación con la Universidad Estatal de Ohio
nos dio estudiantes universitarios
no solo de educación
sino también psicología escolar y trabajo social escolar.
Estos estudiantes se emparejaron con nuestros maestros
para ayudar a nuestros estudiantes más necesitados.
Y todos se beneficiaron.
porque nuestros maestros tuvieron acceso a las últimas ideas a nivel universitario,
y esos estudiantes universitarios tuvieron experiencias de la vida del mundo real
en el aula.
Nuestra asociación con nuestro Hospital de Niños de Nationwide local
nos permitió... están construyendo una clínica de salud en nuestra escuela
dando recursos de salud y salud mental a nuestros estudiantes.
Y nuestros niños también se beneficiaron de esto.
Nuestras ausencias siguieron bajando,
y nuestros niños tuvieron acceso a consejería
a la que pudieron acceder durante el horario escolar.
Y quizás el cambio más grande no fue en D o en los niños en absoluto.
Fue en los adultos.
Los profesores suelen ser buenos
en la planificación y entrega de la instrucción académica,
pero cuando están ante un comportamiento perturbador,
pueden sentirse completamente fuera de su alcance laboral.
Pero al tomarnos en serio el desarrollo emocional de nuestros niños,
pasamos de una filosofía de exclusión.
--tú interrumpes, tú te vas--
a uno de confianza y respeto.
No fue fácil,
pero sentimos en el corazón,
que fue una forma positiva de hacer cambio,
y estoy asombrada por los maestros que dieron ese salto conmigo.
Como parte de nuestro plan de desarrollo profesional personal,
estudiamos la investigación del Dr. Bruce Perry.
y su investigación sobre los efectos de diferentes experiencias infantiles.
en el cerebro del niño en desarrollo.
Aprendimos que algunas de las experiencias de nuestros estudiantes,
como un padre ausente,
una vida casera caótica,
pobreza y enfermedad,
crean un trauma real en el desarrollo de los cerebros.
Sí, trauma.
Sé que es una palabra muy fuerte,
pero nos ayudó a replantearnos y entender los comportamientos que estábamos viendo.
Y esas difíciles experiencias en casa
crean barreras de alambres de púas reales para el aprendizaje,
y tuvimos que encontrar maneras de superarlas.
Nuestros maestros continuaron practicando con planes de lecciones,
haciendo planes de lecciones más cortos con un solo enfoque,
permitiendo que los niños se involucren,
y continuar incorporando pausas de movimiento,
permitiendo a los niños saltar en clase y bailar durante dos minutos seguidos,
porque aprendimos que tomar descansos ayuda a retener nueva información.
Y podría agregar que el "Cha-Cha Slide" ofrece una fiesta de baile corta perfecta.
(Risas)
Vi a los maestros decir: "¿Qué te pasó?",
en lugar de "¿Qué te pasa?"
o "¿Cómo puedo ayudarte?" en lugar de "Vete".
Y esta inversión en nuestros niños marcó grandes diferencias,
Y seguimos viendo alzas en nuestros puntajes académicos.
Me alegra decir que cuando D llegó al cuarto grado,
rara vez se metía en problemas.
Se convirtió en un líder en la escuela,
y este comportamiento se volvió contagioso para otros estudiantes.
Vimos y sentimos que nuestro clima escolar continúa mejorando,
haciéndolo un lugar feliz y seguro no solo para los niños.
sino para los adultos,
a pesar de cualquier influencia exterior.
Avance rápido hasta hoy,
Ahora trabajo con un programa de educación alternativa.
con estudiantes de secundaria
que luchan para funcionar en la escuela secundaria tradicional.
Recientemente he revisado algunas de sus historias.
Muchos de ellos tienen entre 17 y 18 años
y experiencias de drogas,
de salir y entrar del sistema de detención juvenil
y de ser expulsados de la escuela.
Y lo que descubrí fue que muchos de ellos exhiben los mismos comportamientos.
que vi en D. de seis años
Así que no puedo evitar preguntarme:
si estos niños hubieran aprendido estrategias de afrontamiento saludables
cuando las cosas se ponen feas,
¿podrían ahora sobrevivir en una escuela secundaria regular?
No puedo decirlo con seguridad,
pero tengo que decirles que creo que habría ayudado.
Y es hora de que todos nosotros tomemos el desarrollo social y emocional.
de nuestros niños en serio.
Es el momento de dar el paso y decir lo que debemos hacer por nuestros niños.
Si enseñamos a los niños a leer y escribir, y se gradúan,
pero aún no saben cómo manejar las emociones,
¿Cómo serán nuestras comunidades?
Le digo a la gente:
pueden invertir ahora o pagarán más tarde.
Ahora es el momento para que invirtamos en nuestros niños.
Son nuestros futuros ciudadanos
no solo números que pueden o no pueden pasar una prueba.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y vítores)